it's it's it's one of those things where
as much as i i'd love to be like yeah
dude i spent like a hundred grand on
this one gift saved a kid's life it's
like yeah
i don't know
we'll get that one there
yeah yeah yeah hopefully hopefully we'll
get that one there yeah man you know
what i'm gonna get you for christmas
some tesla stock
i know that's what you like nowadays
right
[Laughter]
i don't know i got you ethereum
can you can you even buy
for i brought you some nfts oh great oh
[ __ ] fantastic
i'm watching
on pepe
investment bankers be like yeah bro
don't worry i got you the biggest gift
a solid portfolio of good shocks
that's just such a funny image to me
really you bought me bonds now do you
think i want bonds really in this market
really
i sell some [ __ ] bitcoin some [ __ ]
crypto [ __ ]
doge now
really
in this economy
i'm also like gigger lazy so when i have
an understanding with someone mutually
like that on our birthdays that we do
like lazy gifts yeah um like me daidus
and emily we always just buy each other
like league of legends skins
just like just i don't know why like you
buy each other steam games as well no
not just the legends skins we don't even
play league of legends that's like
negative gift giving yeah exactly
give it to me on my american account
it's not even if i would have played i
wouldn't give away on that account often
so i like the point of them buying skins
for me though that's like that's like me
buying like a [ __ ] tin roll on a
gotcha
yeah
yeah literally honestly
don't tell me bro don't tell me
bro it's like buying ghana [ __ ] uh
you you 23 of me ancestry kids who can
find out who to [ __ ]
um
here's a hundred bucks go to the casino
yeah
you know i mean it's just one of those
things we were like we all agree we're
good enough friends to buy each other
gifts yeah yeah but we're also very lazy
so let's not buy each other gifts that
require effort yeah my presence is a
gift how do you min max you're that guy
not that guy how do you min max gift
buying
what do you mean five you're on the same
gift how do you how do you optimize gift
buying buy from the same gift easy yeah
really yeah uh this is this is a call
like if anyone has any advice on how to
give cool gifts then please teach me how
do you
know that how do you be that cool guy
during christmas how'd you be madeline
how'd you be man
[Music]
do you think i don't like the sound of
my own voice oh guys i ended my own
videos just [ __ ] out just don't buy me
something i can win a crane game please
i got enough of that what if i take you
to a crane game and i win it in front of
you no that's not even worse but
why would it's the experience
watch you win my prize let me win my
prize that i pay for it i don't know i
want darren brown to teach me you know i
i remember when i saw that episode so
darren i don't know if we've talked
about this exact episode before but
we've talked about darren brown
who is uh mentalist right and he has
this one episode where
uh is it simon pegg comes in that's
that's the name of the celebrity right
the ginger guy yeah yeah yeah simon pegg
so he comes in and um he talks about
gift giving and darren brown goes
instead of buying instead of thinking
about what gift to buy someone he buys
someone a gift and convinces them that
that's the gift he wants and that's just
like that's like giga brain man that's
what i need to learn yeah man just go
through the whole phd become one of the
best in the world yeah good luck [ __ ]
[ __ ] i'll [ __ ] do it
i [ __ ] don't just become a good gift
giver spent nine years in college to
become the best gift
um so he uh so he bought him a bmx right
it's a i can't do the clip justice
because i think it's due of like nlp
where he gives simon pegg a speech huh
forgot to say nf
um so yeah so he gives simon pick a
speech and the speech includes some it's
like subtle suggestion of what he should
have or what he should want as a gift
right and he reveals afterwards what he
said and why
everything he said
leads into him wanting a bmx bike this
kind of sounds like [ __ ] to me no
one's going to convince me i don't i
want a bmx bike
i feel like this is going to be hard to
convince me i mean i won't say no at all
i know you're going joe you tell that
you'll tear that [ __ ] up bro he's at the
park but when's the last time you rode a
bmx bike when i was 12 i don't know like
you don't miss that no
you don't no
i really miss it did you never go
through like the skater bmx bike that
kind of phase you know
i was raised in the 90s
yeah you know you never want to relive a
bit of that childhood never never you
don't want to relive that you don't want
to relive it you don't want to relive
the i thought tony hawk was god phase
don't know how much cells go what do you
mean yes yeah so why would you not want
to go on a bmx again
skateboard or a skateboard
i don't care i didn't really like that i
feel he was just the god of extreme
sports in general i like the idea of as
a kid when i tried it i was [ __ ] it i
didn't enjoy it
so that's true so i was like yeah i'm
okay i'm gonna go back inside i hurt
myself i'm gonna go back i'm gonna go
back and play i was just like broke my
leg i saw my friend snap his ankle in
half i think i'm gonna go back inside
and play mario brothers i think i'm okay
i'm gonna go back inside and play tony
hawk
i think i i like i've really liked tony
hawk but i couldn't skate for my life
now yeah
so playing tony hawk was funner than
actual skating yeah
events have gone but yeah you strike me
as the kind of guy
who could not skate
doesn't he yeah it's like the antithesis
of i would not feel comfortable on a
skateboard yeah really you do give off
that vibe i don't know why
wha what a what about you
what about me come on come on come on
come on come curious what about me what
about me because i feel like you know
back in the day there's no 10 hour
youtube tutorials for you to watch yeah
i had to get on the [ __ ] board dance
like [ __ ] tutorials is it
because i can't snowboard is that it no
no actually you get snowballing's fine
you have good efforts
i think i reckon you'll be a good
snowboarder i can't skateboard i can
snowboard yeah i don't know i like i was
really into rollerblading i don't know
rollerblading was like my thing i was
never into skating rollerblading feels
like really white
you know what i mean it feels like the
white version of like like skateboarding
oh really it feels like the i'm a
suburban kid who can't skateboard so i'm
gonna i'm gonna go but i i just i saw
skateboarding as that as well this isn't
skateboarding the most suburban kid yeah
yeah i was about to say yeah
yeah i guess sorry yeah maybe i'm wrong
on that
yeah there
i i did rollerblading so i just assumed
it was the lame thing because i was
doing it see i couldn't rollerblade and
that's why i skated
i couldn't skate which is why i rolled
up later right yes yeah is it yeah it's
like the pokemon versus digimon argument
all over again right
like consume liquid it has been zero
days since god missed his mouth yeah i
mean i i [ __ ] i wish i was better at it
i mean i can snowboard and ski i guess
i'll take that instead yes i wasn't very
i mean i skateboarded but i wasn't you
know doing this
because like i always wanted i never
like had an interest in learning how to
skate but snowboarding always seemed
cool to me in the morning so i like
snowboarding i want to i want to go back
snowboarding when are we going into on
our
next
what is it like when does it start
snowing in japan
right no it depends where you are oh
yeah i mean it's probably already
snowing in hokkaido yeah yeah i mean
japan seasons is like so weird for me
like we're in like deep in well we've
just we're like in november now so it's
winter it doesn't [ __ ] feel like
winter outside no like it's it's so
weird how it's still
it's still [ __ ] hot like i still have
days where i'm just like do i wear a
jumper today or is it still t-shirt
weather and like i'm used to england
yeah and november in england is just no
you you that [ __ ] summer in england
is permanent coat weather yeah let it
let alone [ __ ] know well tell me if
it peaks like peak snow season in japan
is like mid-january yeah it's been it's
been like hot the last few days for some
reason it's been hot this entire [ __ ]
year yeah it went cold for like a week
and it was like psych and then it went
back to like 20 degrees celsius and i'm
like it's it's all the typhoons [ __ ]
it up november bro does this mean we're
gonna get like a really short winter
because i want a long winter i want it
all to be winter gum i don't i don't
want salmon i don't want can we can we
like can we like greek countries
give me my sunshine you can get sunshine
i didn't give me myself i didn't grow
from despicable me steal the sun that's
the real questions
i haven't seen despicable me why it's
good i haven't seen either one of those
movies
in it that's a separate movie
minions is it
a spin-off of the speaker god god
people me one two and three are all
standalone movies one is good two i
haven't seen any of them i've just seen
enough memes through alls moses to know
his best performance today